[Musique]
l'église saint-benoît annie abel s'est
transformée en studio pour
l'enregistrement de projets titanesques
c'est le plus grand projet en mélodie
française jamais enregistrée dans
l'histoire du disque est le plus grand
projet lyrique jamais enregistrés au
canada
[Musique]
14 des plus grandes voix du pays et
enregistrent l'intégrale des oeuvres du
prolifique compositeur jules massenet
entre autres marie nicole lemieux
j'ai découvert chez massenet cette
sensualité vraiment très belle et 7
c'est un amoureux quand on dit amoureux
ça s'entend dans sa musique je me plais
à dire c'est un peu le populeux elton
john de la mélodie française en fait il
écrivait ça comme il faisait des succès
faisait des tubes sans arrêt les 320
mélodies de massenet seront réunis sur
trois coffrets un projet dont la
réalisation a d'ailleurs été facilitée
par la pandémie
c'est vraiment très beau côté de la
pandémie sont si je puis m'exprimer
ainsi
ça nous offre justement l'opportunité de
chanter ensemble avec différents
chanteurs qui en d'autres temps serait
aux quatre coins de la planète
la production dont le budget avoisine
les 2 175 mille dollars a été en partie
financée par un couple de mystérieux
donateur baisse de la pure philanthropie
le bonheur et le plaisir de la musique
plonger dans l'oeuvre de masse l'es6
rendre hommage la mélodie française elle
ne recherche immense entre ça parce que
au moins les deux tiers de ce matériel
lakic a été très peu ou jamais
enregistrée les chanteurs sont
accompagnés par un piano exceptionnel où
l'instrument comme possiblement celui
que massenet avait c'est au piano erard
donc c'est une marque française très
reconnue qui date de 1850 donc de la
jeunesse de matinée c'est un piano qui
est très différent des autres parce que
vous voyez par exemple clavier un peu
plus court et un petit peu plus étroite
les premiers disques de l'intégrale de
massenet seront lancés en 2021 ici nabi
alexandre chartier radio-canada mirabel
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]